Cooper today you go to boarding school
no sick cooper cooper sit
Cooper come
when you after your boarding school
Cooper you're gonna stay in your place
you're gonna listen you're not gonna
rush out of doors you're gonna be a
gooder boy because right now you're
already a good boy you're such a good
boy okay we gotta take a picture of you
because you're so little when you come
back in six weeks you're gonna be so
much bigger are you ready
are you ready
so I'm in the car because today we're
dropping coopy coops off to um his
obedient school that's the same school
we took Mia the greatest dog in the
world too we loved it so much that we
decided to do the same for Cooper just
because it's just going to be easier for
all of us to be on the exact same
program we all get the same commands we
all understand each other and we all
speak a Common Language so I'm here
right now to drop him off and I'm kind
of sad but like super stoked because
he's just gonna have an easy life once
we all just get on the same page so
koopy you ready dude
you ready my little cutie Mia
you are elegant
hi coops
hey dude you don't even know what's
about to happen Okay so he's gonna be
gone for six weeks of just intense
training getting him programmed if you
will that sounds wild but
um so I have food for him I they
recommend that they eat blue so I got
this for him and because he's on like an
antibiotic right now they want him to
consume it and he has baby ass teeth
they want him to consume it with some
wet food so we combine this with this I
have a little bit of medicine for him
it's um probiotics and then just the
antibiotics because he had a little
runny nose he's great now but we still
want to keep that going some pill
Pockets so I'm going to hand this all
over to them with him and we should be
good to go
it's literally just minutes he's already
paying attention look at that
she's already having him follow her
she's placing him on these different
cons he's healing oh he loves her
yay look at how happy he is and he has
no idea he's already learning he's at
school
good job coops
good job
oh goodbye
I'm so excited for him
yeah those are big
okay we can go home
so what's this area
oh okay so this is the area where
they're gonna work the young coops will
he be with any other pups when it comes
to training or is it just by himself
when they have when they are fully
trained already
we
we put them with other dogs as a
distraction okay um
good boy
look at this space you're gonna have so
much fun dude good job
he's gonna have a blast
[Applause]
your turn pet me now
oh my turn my turn okay I'll bet you
I'll fetch you okay see you
[Applause]
good job so when it comes to the
training he'll just do the socializing
and then just the listening commands
good job dude
see how happy is it makes me so excited
he's gonna be learning so much have such
an easy life we'll be on the same
program
he's gonna be the best boy
oh yeah you want it now
up to you I don't want to interrupt your
day up to you and Karen's good with dogs
too so he doesn't care so you said that
the dogs do what here they swim and have
fun in here and then they get them to
jump off of the waterfalls how fun will
coops do that or is that like a
different program
no it's just a part of the boarding oh
okay we can teach them to swim or if
they already swim we swim with them how
fun
oh
look at that and then what's this for
just like as a motivator
the line yeah they pull
I think when they let go oh
yeah
look at that
he's like I hear water
nope okay
this they pull oh and it tugs they
thought they play top of work on their
own how cool oh man what an awesome
playground
and then they punch
you're teaching them how to box
what you teach them how to box oh I do
oh for you
I was trying to make a joke that the
dog's punch by its you're the one that's
trading
okay never mind my joke my joke failed
they trained personal protection okay
they box you okay I messed up
you know we're gonna have a friend to
the training room let me show you
something oh sure sure
yeah of course
look at this beautiful boy
okay
[Music]
go ahead I'm ready
so this is my parents
[Music]
so she's doing nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
he's beautiful
okay
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
holy crap
[Music]
[Applause]
watch
[Music]
what's up
[Applause]
now we're leaving
sure
you shouldn't keep on bite me
oh yeah
[Applause]
are out foreign
that is wonderful
oh how safe I would feel so damn safe
knowing that at any moment I could say
what's the one I'm not gonna say the
word but I could just say my word and
then no and my dog's in a lunch and
protect me how
protected would you feel I would feel
it's so good
[Music]
and what is that called that like if
they wanted that service what is that
called
oh okay yeah I feel protected so then
you would just have the dog or can I
bring with a dog
so like her she's for sale you said
right but he's for sale sorry and then I
could do that with Cooper too if I
wanted to yeah
oh okay which he looks like
right now if we call this
is valid at the bottoman
[Applause]
um
that would be good for this age then it
is
in martial arts his own yeah yeah with
tiger
[Applause]
oh my God
even that I love that um they have to
have the specific Gene to do it which
you know that like if the person that
goes yeah we can do that with any dog
then you know they're being phony
baloney but like this is cool yeah
[Applause]
so all his Barons
um grandparents have been working and
getting titled titles in protection
sport so that's why you gonna he has
Chinese
oh my God many times
like with uh
installed and see how far he can get
into the bike it's like he's a black
belt
he's a stallion or you can get some dogs
that can be less than that but still
showing protection oh that's so good
okay we'll see we don't know yet we'll
see oh what a beautiful dog
look at how happy this girl is she's
back has so many Waggles in her little
tail right now look at this guy what a
stud
Mia
get in Mia
look at her she's so excited
will she do it will she do it
[Applause]
whoa this guy is awesome
look at them
just seeing how happy me is really is a
true Testament
of how much she really really loves this
place because it could have been super
traumatizing right because you're
training these dogs and there's some
really bad trainers out there that will
like severely traumatize your dog but
none of that with me look at her she's
just like back at home here
look at her all of love
oh
Cooper you ready dude I'm so excited for
you my boy look at that guy
oh he's having the best time ever
I'm next man look at him
comia comia watch go jump inside
do it Mia
it really does make me happy to see how
happy she is because I'm like Cooper's
gonna go through the same thing if he's
gonna be so happy to be here too
now Mia yuck Mia